[Music]
apparently a guy in Philadelphia crashed
his car into a fried chicken restaurant
okay
then he got out of his car and he
removed all his clothes and began
pleasuring himself in a busy
intersection until the police arrived
you see that article I'm not making this
up I saw that article and it got me
thinking what kind of pervert drives
into a chicken restaurant then gets
naked and starts masturbating it makes
no sense at all to do something how was
that Alan why don't we just cut to that
guy oh sorry about that Conan just a
camera miscue won't happen again
that's awful I'd like to apologize I'm
really sorry anyway getting back to this
shameless horny creep the guy thinks he
can get away Alan what the hell
I'm really sorry Conan I was trying to
figure out exactly what I did wrong last
time and while I was trying to figure it
out I did it again but I did figure it
out now so we're good I am very sorry
very sorry okay you just embarrassed a
member of our audience twice now well I
won't do that again all right thank you
anyway back to this perv this guy has a
bizarre fetish for chicken and he needs
to take his clothes
[Applause]
what Alan why was there chicken clucking
when you cut to the guy Coenen you're
not gonna believe this but a mouse just
ran across the control board unreal
anyway as I was saying I'd even know
what you'd call a creep who publicly
masturbates in front of a chicken
restaurant and Alan what was that
there was a product placement for a new
sponsor how could that how could that
possibly be for a sponsor it's a jewelry
company that makes necklaces for hens
and roosters here dissolve a check it
out that's incredibly stupid but all
right I guess that could happen all
right please get it together Alan sure
thing boss all right now as I was saying
it's
[Applause]
what was that another new sponsor okay
listen I don't care all of this stops
now no more graphics no more sound
effects no more ads featuring a member
of our audience is that clear Alan
crystal clear you won't see any of that
stuff again okay I'm really very sorry
you came here to see a show and you
shouldn't be exposed today we're we're
we're we're looks like we got ourselves
an audience member who likes chicken
more than I and we wrote him a special
song when you get your whip of chicken
and your wrist it start to plug in here
do you know it's finger-licking when
you're walking started getting pleasure
[Music]
I forgot
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry Onan that was supposed to be for
my daughter's second-grade music okay
that explains everything